[Musique]
bonsoir et bienvenue dans élémentaire
l'émission de Public Sénat qui cherche à
mettre en perspective les éléments de
l'actualité et à leur donner de la
profondeur de champ la 5eme République à
66 ans c'est-à-dire qu'elle va bientôt
égaler le record de longévité de la 3e
République qui pourtant paraissait une
exception dans la proverbiale
instabilité institutionnelle française
songez que nous avons changé de
constitution tous les 15 ans depuis 1789
alors que les États-Unis don la
Constitution date de 1788 nen nont
jamais changé cert ils l'ont amendé 27
fois cette Constitution a souvent été
critiquée à ses débuts rappelons-nous du
coup d'état permanent l'expression
célèbre de Françis mitéran et puis elle
a paru faire consensus mais voilà que
depuis une dizaines d'années elle est à
nouveau sur la celllette les critiques
se
multiplient on l'accuse d'être
dictatorial ou au contraire d'être
instable on l'a vu récemment avec les
les contestations des des états
d'urgence avec les gilets jaunes avec la
contestation au moment de la retraite de
l'usage du 493 ou bien avec les
vicissitudes de la loi sur l'immigration
qu'en est-il réellement est-ce que c'est
une constitution usée vieillie est-ce
qu'au contraire elle est
solide est-ce qu'elle doit être
transformée ou est-ce qu'elle doit être
confortée c'est cela dont nous allons
débattre dans cette émission et pour
nous aider dans C dans cette tâche une
universitaire et un praticien du droit
constitutionnel l'universitaire c'est
Anne Charlen beina bonsoir bonsoir vous
êtes maître de conférence à rouan et à
sciencesp Paris en scienceces politiqu
et en droit constitutionnel et vous
venez de publier textes constitutionnels
et politiques au PUF et le praticien
c'est Manuel Vals bonsoir Monsieur le
Premier Ministre bonsoir ai-je besoin de
vous présenter vous avez été ministre
vous avez été premier ministre vous avez
été député vous avez été maire mais je
soulligne un point c'est que vous avez
été trois fois à Matignon vous l'avez
été avec Michel Rocard de 88 à à 91 une
expérience de la majoritaire lative vous
l'avez été avec Lionel Jospin de 1997 à
2001 une expérience de la cohabitation
et puis enfin vous avez été vous-même le
titulaire du poste de 2014 à 2016 donc
vous avez expérimenté de près le fond
fement de nos institutions nous allons
si vous le voulez bien d'abord essayer
de rappeler brièvement ce que sont les
traits de ces institutions de cette
constitution ensuite de voir qu'est-ce
qui motive les critiques actuelles et
enfin de voir qu'est-ce qu'on doit
changer si on doit changer quelque chose
à cette constitution je vais commencer
avec vous Anne
Charlen si je résume les choses en
disant cela vous allez me dire si je me
trompe ou pas le général de GA et Michel
Debré ont
souhaité rompre avec l'instabilité de la
4e République et pour ça ils ont ont
pris trois mesures majeures la première
c'est un un système qui n'est ni
parlementaire comme au Royaume-Uni ni
présidentiel comme aux États-Unis qui
est un mixte des deux puisque certes le
gouvernement est responsable devant
l'assemblée mais devant le Parlement
mais le l'exécutif peut dissoudre
l'Assemblée deuxième point ils ont
institué toujours dans cet objectif de
stabilité le parlementarisme rationalisé
c'est-à-dire qu'en fait l'exécutif à la
main sur pour parti sur le
fonctionnement du Parlement son ordre du
jour la dont il vote et cetera et puis
troisème chose qui n'est pas dans la
Constitution mais qui est qui est lié au
aux ordonnances de 1958 à la loi disons
et qui est un scrutin majoritaire
uninominal à deux tours qui assure une
majorité au Parlement est-ce que je je
résume utilement les traits
caractéristiques de notre Constitution
on retrouve tout son caractère hybride
parce que c'est vrai que cette 5e
République dès la naissance et c'est la
loi constitutionnelle du 3 juin 58 qui
donne en fait un un guide au général de
gaauulle qui esttant templi de de cette
ambigué on a un vrai régime
parlementaire ça il faut le rappeler
c'est un régime parlementaire parce
qu'il y a cette responsabilité du
Gouvernement devant le Parlement et
cette possibilité de dissoudre qui
existe aussi en Grande-Bretagne donc on
est vraiment dans un régime
parlementaire mais la touche
d'originalité c'est la touche goliste
c'est le président qui reste l'arbitre
c'est le terme auquel il est attaché et
c'est encore dans l'article 5 de notre
Constitution c'est-à-dire que le
président doit être en quelque sorte
celui qui va donner le cap intellectuel
et c'est là qu'on va rompre avec la
tradition le scrutin majorita est aussi
quelque chose auquel le général de
Gaulle tient beaucoup pour rompre avec
l'instabilité de la 4e et pour installer
des majorités qui tiennent et qui
permettent à un gouvernement de tenir
sur une législature d'être en tout cas
probant l'idée était d'arriver à ce que
cet équilibre instable tienne sur deux
têtes de l'exécutif le président et le
Premier ministre néanmoins on verra que
la pratique des institutions a beaucoup
affaibli Prem ministre alors vous me
tendz une perche pour interroger manuel
Val sur un deuxième point qui est deux
mesures la 1ère en 1962 l'élection au
suffrage universel du président de la
République et puis la seconde qui a été
prise par accord entre Jacques Chirac et
Lionel Jospin en 2000 avec la réduction
à 5 ans du mandat présidentiel est-ce
que ces deux mesures n'ont pas
déséquilibrer le rapport entre le
Président de la République et le Premier
ministre au profit du premier en
fabriquant un hyper président qui est
l'une des source de contestation
aujourd'hui peut-être du fonctionnement
de nos institutions déséquilibré
renforcer euh les pouvoirs au profit du
président de la République en 1962 c'est
incontestable même si l'autorité du
général de Gaulle depuis 1958 était
total mais en effet pour ses successeurs
euh c'est sans doute vrai la légitimité
c'est le président de la République qui
l'a et c'est pour cela que les Français
sont très attachés me semble-t-il à
l'élection au suffrage direct universel
du président de la République euh quant
aux quinena qui ont fait dire beaucoup
de choses parce que je crois que
beaucoup est dans la pratique dans la
pratique politique notamment entre les
deux têtes de l'exécutif selon la
composition du couple du du haut je
crois que cela correspondait au temps
aujourd'hui démocratique euh la
communication aux États-Unis c'est 4 ans
dans la plupart des démocraties
parlementaires c'est maximum 5 ans mais
c'est en général 4 ans parfois c'est
même 3 ans donc cela correspond je crois
à ce qu'il fallait des mandats de 7 ans
euh avec une réélection possible je
crois POS me semble-t-il de toute façon
les mêmes problèmes alors dans les
critiques aussi c'est pour vous la
question van Charlen dans les critiques
aussi qu'on fait la Constitution il y a
la montée progressive du gouvernement
des juges parce que certes entre
guillemets parce que certes la
Constitution initialement a prévu
l'existence d'un contrôle de
constitutionnalité mais le Conseil
constitutionnel c'est lui-même renforcé
au fur et à mesure des années au point
qu'aujourd'hui on l'a vu avec la loi sur
l'immigration dont on va faire l'arbitre
dont il va dont il va être l'arbitre au
point qu'aujourd'hui on peut on peut
certains contestent le fait qu'une
autorité non élue et ses prérogatives en
effet au départ le général de Gaulle
répond aux questions en annonçant que la
seule Cour suprême qui existe dans la
constitution de 58 c'est le peuple et il
n'a pas tort c'est encore lui qui a le
dernier mot aujourd'hui la montée en
puissance du Conseil constitutionnel je
ne suis pas sûr qu'elle soit
complètement contre à GAM parce que au
fond c'est vrai que les rédacteurs n'ont
pas cette idée au départ mais dans le
concert des nations des démocraties
européenne un conseil constitutionnel
diminué nous amènerait quand même à
avoir du mal avec notre titre de patrie
des Droits de l'Homme donc ce Conseil
constitutionnel qui garantit nos pactes
fondamentaux nos droits fondamentaux
toute l'intégrité de la Constitution je
crois profondément qu'il est nécessaire
qu'il est légitime alors les juges ne
sont pas élus mais ce sont eux qui
gardent la Constitution d'ailleurs la
figure à l'entrée du Conseil
constitutionnel du du Sphinx c'est cette
idée d'être le gardien donc je crois
vraiment qu'il est légitime l'idée est
d'essayer de d'éviter de de de mettre à
mon av avis dans dans un mauvais match
la légitimité élective du Parlement et
les juges les deux ne font pas la même
chose mais attention à ce que nos droits
fondamentaux soit conservé c'est la
volonté profonde du peuple critique
qu'on a adressé aussi à ces institutions
et vous les avez vous l'z vécu de
l'intérieur récemment enfin on certains
disent que ça n'est pas le texte de 58
ce sont ces réformes ultérieures qui
l'ont déséquilibré et notamment deux
réformes qui sont liés à ce qui qui ont
été initiés par le président Sarkozi la
limitation de l'usage du 493 c'est ce
que je vais dire est paradoxal et le
fait que on est rendu le mandat du
Président de la République on les limité
à deux mandats rendant impossible sa
réélection autrement dit on aurait
affaibli la capacité de l'exécutif à
mener sa politique ou à imposer son
autorité par la combinaison et c'est ça
qui expliquerait les difficultés que N
rencontre et vous vous avez connu une
majorité relative avec Michel rard et
puis vous vous êtes le spectateur de la
de des événements actuels oui j'ai j'ai
connu une majorité relative avec Michel
Rocard au cours du second septénat de
François mitteran progressivement
entraîné par par la maladie par par des
affaires et puis par la fin d'une époque
tout simplement et
puis comme comme premier ministre les
difficultés d'un président de la
République face aussi à sa propre
majorité et les frondeurs j'en ai fait
évidemment l'expérience la réforme
constitutionnelle de Nicolas Sarkozi
2008 est importante peut-être pas aller
jusqu'au bout des préconisations de ce
qu'on a appelé la commission baladure
mais encore une fois il me semble que la
limitation à deux quinquenas du
président de la République ces réformes
importantes ou la limitation du 493 ne
change pas
fondamentalement la pratique et
l'exercice du pouvoir parce que je crois
qu'il y a un problème c'est qu'on on on
on critique la 5e République euh euh
cette constitution alors que les
problèmes auxquels nous faisons face
sont ceux de la crise démocratique que
connaissent toutes les grandes nations
moderne euh et et occidental euh la
perte des idéologies la fin des grands
partis le rôle de la globalisation le
rôle évidemment euh euh de de l'Europe
c'est ça parfois qui entrave l'action
politique mais la 5e République c'est la
stabilité et comme le disait mon vieil
ami Guy Carcasson avec qui j'ai
travaillé quand j'étais avec Michel
Rocard dans les relations avec le
Parlement elle est extrêmement plastique
et puis très
souvent le Parlement et notamment
l'Assemblée nationale et les députés ne
se rendent pas compte du pouvoir qu'ils
ont la capacité d'exercer ne l'exerc pas
jusqu'au bout eux-mêmes intègrent
parfois la la la la force la puissance
du président de la République d'une
manière qui d'une certaine manière les
entrave quand on entend une certain
nombre de critiques alors elles sont
exagérées quand on parle d'ilibéralisme
ou quand on a parlé de dictature c'était
à l'époque des gilets jaunes on pointe
quand même du doigt je reviens au sujet
jet précédent l'hyperprésidence est-ce
que vous dites la crise démocratique
mais est-ce que
l'hyperprésidence que la Constitution et
ses réformes successiv ont organisé
est-ce qu'elle est raccord avec l'idéal
horizontal des sociétés modernes euh
sociétés modernes demande de choses
contradictoires l'autorité et
l'horizontalité en même temps c'est un
autre en même temps étant né en Espagne
ayant vu voter mon père pour la première
fois en
1977 quand on parle de dictature nous
concernant euh je souris et je suis
accablé et enfin 3oisème remarque sur
l'hyperprésidence alors peut-être c'est
une des conséquences du quinquena de
président élus pour la première fois qui
veulent tout de suite répondre à
l'attente populaire mais je pense que
c'est une question de pratique et je
considère que le Président de la
République notamment au cours de ce
deuxe quinquena je veux parler
d'Emmanuel Macron se trompe dans dans
dans la gestion qui est la sienne des
rapports avec le Premier ministre son
rôle r d'arbitre de celui qui donne le
sens intellectuel pour reprendre votre
expression ne laisse pas suffisamment de
place au Premier ministre François
Hollande m'a laissé cet espace c'est la
pratique donc c'est moins la lettre des
institutions que la pratique de ce point
de vue d'ailleurs par rapport à l'esprit
gaulien de la responsabilité c'est vrai
qu'on a vu au cours des décennies
précédentes on a vu que un président
pouvait voir élu une une chambre qui lui
était hostile cohabitation sans juger
qu'il devait démissionner on a vu
c'était François mitteron et puis
ensuite c était Jacques Chirac on a vu
un président qui perdait un référendum
c'était Jacques Chirac avec le présid
traité constitutionnel sont considéré
que ça devait engager sa
responsabilité j'ai entendu que l'actuel
Premier ministre n'était pas déterminé à
engager sa responsabilité devant le
Parlement est-ce qu'on a est-ce qu'on ne
s'est pas éloigné de l'esprit de
responsabilité des institutions au
risque de donner le sentiment au peuple
que le le fonctionnement démocratique
n'est pas complet profondément je crois
que la carence de la pratique politique
de la 5e République aujourd'hui se situe
sur le terrain de la responsabilité en
effet parce que si en 58 le texte peut
apparaître équilibré c'est notamment
parce qu'il y a cette responsabilité
informelle du président du général de
Gaulle qui à chaque scrutin à chaque
référendum engage finalement son avenir
dans l'opinion il estimait que on ne
pouvait présider qu'à partir du moment
où on était connecté avec sa base et ça
c'est quelque chose qui s'est
aujourd'hui profondément perdu j'ajoute
quelque chose d'un peu sucré salé dans
ce débat mais je ne crois pas que
l'hyperprésidence fasse partie du texte
de la Constitution de la 5e République
aujourd'hui rien n'oblige un président
de la République à intervenir dans une
commission mixte paritaire rien n'oblige
le président de la République à imposer
des noms à son premier ministre pour
composer le gouvernement l'espace
politique c'est au président de la
République de le donner et en ce sens la
pratique institution est aujourd'hui
intégré aujourd'hui intégré tellement
cette hyper présidence qu'elle
déresponsabilise le Premier ministre
qu'elle déresponsabilise l'Assemblée
nationale dans un sens qui déplaitt au
peuple puisque ça nous donne
l'impression que cette constitution est
déséquilibrée là où elle pourrait tout à
fait à mon avis permettre une autre
pratique voyez manuel Vals opiner je
sais pas s'il existe un club des premi
ministres mais s'il existe et quand vous
échangez vos expé il est secret mais
est-ce que en échangeant vos expériences
avec vos prédécesseurs est-ce que vous
avez le senti en effet que la pratique
des institutions s'est détérioré qu'au
fond c'est plutôt elle qui est en cause
que la lettre des de la Constitution
elle-même oui je le crois moi je pense
qu'il faut revenir peut-être aux
origines de la 5e République l'idée de
changer ça c'est très français on a une
constitution extrêmement plastique
souple
solide je pense que nous avons résisté
avec François Hollande alors que nous
étions face au front deur avec une crise
économique évidemment face à une crise
terroriste majeure je pense que dans une
autre démocratie dans un autre régime
plutôt nous aurions volé en éclat cela a
permis de gouverner stabiliser cette
stabilité qu'a voulu c'est le génie du
général de Gaulle il sait parfaitement
ce que nous sommes nous ce peuple de
Gaulois réfractaire j'aurais aimé
échanger avec Michel Debray ou avec
georgees Pompidou sur notamment le début
des de la pratique de la 5e République
c'est d'ailleurs très étonnant en lisant
les mémoires les carnets de d'Alain
perfit on voit qu'il y a un débat au
sein du Conseil des ministres notamment
sur la guerre d'Algérie alors il est
vrai que le gouvernement repose plutôt
sur une coalition il y a des socialistes
aussi qui sont présents dans ces
premiers conseils des ministres mais je
crois en effet que c'est une question de
pratique et de responsabilité de ce
point de vue-là l'usage du référendum
euh pour être davantage euh mise en
œuvre au nom de cette responsabilité et
de cet appel au peuple alors pas à
chaque fois de manière tragique pas avec
l'idée de rester ouou de partir mais
parce que dans l'idée du général de
Gaulle et dans les bases de la 5e
République dans ses fondements dans son
ADN il y a en effet et cette
responsabilité et cette peup et cet
appel constant au au peuple qui qui fait
partie de nos de notre démocratie mais
on a vu récemment que parmi les
modifications de la Constitution qui
aurait
pu viser à la moderniser il y avait
l'idée d'étendre le champ du référendum
mais la crainte que cet usage ne
devienne un mésusage et qu'on en profite
pour violer la constitution à travers
l'expression directe du souffrage
universel apparemment a retenu le le le
le les partis politiques vous pensez
l'un et l'autre que c'est une réforme
qui aurait dû être menée à son terme à
force d'avoir peur du peuple c'est ce
dernier qui à un moment ou l'autre vous
emporte donc je pense que cette pratique
elle me paraît importante et ce qui a
été dit aussi me paraît très important
je je le répète il faut que le Président
de la République soit je parle pas que
d'Emmanuel Macron mais soit à sa place
et qu'il laisse le gouvernement
gouverner et qui laisse sa majorité
aussi exercer ses compétences sinon on
étouffe le débat politique je ne crois
pas nécessairement que cette réforme du
champ du référendum aurait renforcé le
référendum c'est son usage qui pourrait
renforcer ce référendum il faut le texte
de notre article 11 est assez large il
pourrait permettre au peuple de se
prononcer sur des réformes sociales
économiques environnementales
institutionnell et toutes ces questionsl
on les a finalement très peu utilisé
sous la 5e République où ce sont
essentiellement des traités européens
qui ont permis au peuple de se prononcer
donc je crois nécessairement que il
suffit c'est un pouvoir propre du
président hein donc c'est un il suffit
d'appuyer sur le bouton hein pour que ça
démarre donc si le président de la
République l'utilise plus régulièrement
si on installe la culture référendaire
peut-être qu'on pourrait arriver à une
pratique plus équilibrée nos
institution une autre critique qu'on
fait à nos institutions pas seulement en
France mais aussi en France et peut-être
plus en France c'est qu'elles sont trop
représentative entre guillemets et
qu'ell qu'ell ne ne correspondent plus
au besoins d'expression directe du
peuple que les que les sociétés
d'opinion renforcent et accentuent alors
on a cherché
notamment par les débats citoyens les
conférences de consensus est-ce que
c'est une voie
d'amélioration de la des institutions
françaises ou est-ce que ça vous paraît
vous à la lumière de la théorie et vous
Monsieur le Premier Ministre à la
lumière de la pratique un pisalé qui qui
est subalterne par rapport à à
l'expression centrale du suffrage
universel moi je crois ce que disaient
nos constituants 1795 qu'une
constitution elle doit s'adapter aux
générations futures et que finalement
elle doit non seulement être plastique
mais adapté avec son temps et l'appel du
peuple à plus de participation est en
effet très fort dans les démocraties
modernes ça renforcerait la société de
la confiance donc je crois que des
démocraties comme l'Italie qui utilisent
le référendum abrogatif ou tu utilise le
référendum sous forme de pétition avec
ce que nous avons nous comme référendum
d'initiative partagé qui est très
verrouillé nous montre que on on
pourrait à mon avis lâcher des verrous
libérer cette expression populaire je
crois que c'est vraiment quelque chose
qui pourrait permettre à à la 5e
République de s'adapter à son temps et
donc je ne suis pas sûr que ça soit
purement une réforme cosmétique en effet
le référendum d'initiative citoyenne
alors le référendum d'initiative
citoyenne en effet était appelé des vœux
des gilets jaunes je pense qu'en fait
c'est un type de pétition il y a quatre
types de référendum le référendom pour
rappeler des gouvernants qu'on appelle
le recall qui existe aux États-Unis qui
là vous permet de rappeler un gouvernant
qui est quand même une forme très
extrême que peu de démocratie
occidentale le rappeler de le rappeler
c'est-à-dire tout simplement dire qu'il
n'est plus élu que le peuple ne veut
plus connecter avec lui le référ
abrogatif où vous abrogez une loi du
Parlement le référendum que nous
connaissons où nous ratifions une
question et le référendum sur
participation ça serait bien que nous
essayons au moins de combiner plusieurs
formes de référendum dans notre
Constitution ça lui permettrait à mon
avis une belle capacité d'adaptabilité
vous paraît pas trop dangereux pour la
démocratie représentative mais le souci
d'horizontalité de participation le rôle
des réseaux sociaux la critique de
l'impuissance du politique à l'heure je
le répète de la globalisation et de
l'Europe pour ce qui concerne notre
continent ce sont des sentiments
partagés dans toutes les démocraties
elles sont toutes en crise donc plutôt
que de changer notre texte fondamental
qui encore une fois correspond beaucoup
à ce que nous sommes il faut faire appel
en effet à d'autres pratiques j'étais
maire vous l'avez rappelé les élus
locaux aussi entre conseil de quartier
comité de quartier consultation
rôle de de de l'Internet et des réseaux
sociaux chacun chacun s'adapte à à à à
cette attente forte des euh des gens de
de participer davantage à la décision à
la décision politique bon et puis et
puis ensuite il peut y avoir d'autres
réflexions de modification d'évolution
vous avez dit quelque chose de très
juste au début de notre conversation
c'est c'est c'est le rôle essentiel du
scrutin majoritaire qui n'est pas
inscrit dans la Constitution mais qui a
changé énormément avec l'élection au
souvrage universel et direct du
président de la République bien
évidemment qui a changé la stratégie de
tous les partis politiques a commencé la
stratégie personnelle de François
miteran qui a qui a vu la a une occasion
un jour d'arriver au au pouvoir bon donc
mais mais sur les fondements de des
institutions la 5e République elles sont
solide au à ceux qui les pratiquent
d'être intelligent à l'écoute et de les
faire évoluer mais mais dans leur
pratique et pas dans leur fondement je
je reviens un mot sur le la réélection
du président de la République vous vous
considérez que le fait queon limite à
deux mandats euh sa possibilité
d'élection ne l'affaiblit pas dans son
second mandat dans dans par une analyse
alors je prends du recul par rapport aux
praticiens que j'ai été mais en
regardant l'histoire des démocraties qui
nous entourent nos propres pratique 10
an à tous les niveaux hein c'est
beaucoup il a une forme de Al il peut y
avoir des cas exceptionnels je veux bien
le croire mais au fond 10 ans dans un
pouvoir qui use vous êtes très isolé
soumis à à beaucoup de de pression cela
me semble être maximum bien
évidemment la bonne la bonne durée ch
c'est votre point de vue aussi je ne
sais pas si j'aurais systématisé cela
dans la Constitution puisque c'est vrai
que si on remonte dans notre histoire on
se serait privé de Clémenceau de
Gambetta et cetera donc parfois des
grands hommes peuvent permettre à une
nation de tenir et il peut y avoir des
besoins exceptionnels que la
Constitution ménageait néanmoins c'est
vrai que il y a là encore une
constitution qui s'adapte avec son temps
euh il est dans l'opinion très important
de changer les tête Emmanuel Macron
avait compris ça d'ailleurs en arrivant
au pouvoir en voulant limiter la
succession des mandats dans le temps
même pour les parlementaires parce que
au fond l'idée de faire confiance aussi
longtemps au même tête affaiblit un
petit peu la la démocratie les
institutions donc je crois que même si
systématiser cela n'est pas forcément
nécessaire dans le texte en tout cas
l'idée est que le texte soit adapté à
une volonté de l'opinion et en ce sens
je pense que 10 ans c'est en effet assez
équilibré et on pourrait vous rétorquer
que le suffrage universel a déjà
manifesté qu'il était capable d'éviter
que des présidents ne soient réélus pour
10 ans il a sanctionné plusieurs d'entre
eux donc l'élection est le moment sans
sans qu'on est à à légiférer sur la
durée du mandat où le peuple s'exprime
pour mettre un terme ou pas au mandat
s'il le juge nécessaire enfin bon c'est
un débat vous savez Cléo a gouverné deux
fois de fois 3 ans un peu plus pour la
deème fois Bloom 11 mois et puis ensuite
peu de temps euh mes France mes France
quelques semaines enfin ou 11 mois euh
ils sont restés dans euh ils sont restés
dans l'histoire d'où la force de la 5e
République qui a permis cette stabilité
qui a permis l'alternance qui a permis à
la gauche de gouverner longtemps aussi
donc ceux qui notamment à gauche veulent
des grands soirs concernant la
Constitution oublie l'histoire et cette
stabilité est-ce que finalement au fond
les critiques qui sont faites à la
Constitution ne ne soulligne pas le fait
qu'elle tient bien le l'épreuve du temps
par exemple la majorité relative vous
l'avez vécu euh avec Michel Rocard euh
et d'une certaine manière avec vos
frondeurs interne donc vous les aviez
c'était une majorité relative inommée
bah au fond c'est c'est ce que vivent
des démocraties parlementaires qui
cherchent des compromis alors c'est pas
l'habitude ce qu'on a vécu au moment de
la loi sur l'immigration est-ce que ça
n'est pas une une pratique qui est assez
usuelle dans d'autres démocraties
parlementaires oui mais Michel Rocard en
88 au nom d'ailleurs du slogan de
François mitteran emportait largement
cette élection présidentielle la France
unie a mis en place une pratique grâce à
l'agilité intellectuelle de gu Carcasson
je le rappelle une deuxième fois avec un
ministre de relations au Parlement plus
personne ne s'en rappelle mais qui était
un grand politique était genspren on a
trouvé des des des majorités ici avec le
Parti communiste là avec les centristes
là avec les députés ultramarins et et ce
qui se passe aujourd'hui c'est
précisément qu'Emmanuel Macron au
lendemain des élections législatives qui
lui ont donné qu'une majorité relative
mais une majorité cependant n'a pas tenu
compte n'a pas intégré les leçons de
cela et lui-même n'a pas cherché les
coalitions nécessaires sinon plutôt ô
imposer voire à déstabiliser ces dites
oppositions et là il s'est trompé aussi
sur la manière de gérer les éléments de
la majorité relative c'est votre point
de vue aussi au fond quand on regarde
des démocraties parlementaires qu'on
cité en exempme je pense au Royaume-Uni
elles ont été capables de de faire le
brexit donc c'est pas forcément qu'elle
soit plus sage que que nos propres
institutions non je sais pas quel est
votre point de vue moi j'ai le sentiment
que on peut citer la Grande-Bretagne on
peut citer l'Espagne l'Allemagne
beaucoup de grandes démocraties arrivent
à gouverner carrément dans des systèmes
de coalition c'est-à-dire avec des
gouvernements de projets donc si le
gouvernement représente aujourd'hui sous
la 5e République son président en tout
cas la majorité relative elle peut
permettre une extrêmement belle
diversité d'opinion sur laquelle à mon
avis il y a un manque qui est encore
celui de la pratique politique et je
rejoins ce qui a été dit un manque en
amont les textes se travaillaient en
amont en 88 c'est-à-dire que on allait
chercher les majorités avant de
présenter les textes aujourd'hui on
fonctionne de manière totalement inverse
on concilie on essaie de concerter sur
des avantprjets dont on n'a pas encore
l'articulation globale et puis on impose
ensuite ça n'est pas comme ça qu'on peut
gouverner dans une majorité relative
mais c'est un beau défi que le peuple a
lancé aux institutions et surtout à ceux
qui la pratiquent bon cette émission
s'achève si je comprends bien on est
plutôt dans 5e République encore que
dans 5e République stop pour prendre le
titre qu'on avait retenu guit Carcasson
que vous avez cité monsieur le Premier
ministre et qui était en effet l'un des
plus brillants constitutionnalistes
français dont l'absence
est se fait sentir gu Casson avait écrit
la 5e République est plus forte que les
hommes qui la font vivre elle les soumet
à ses lois et n'entend pas se soumettre
au leur tout à dit on va voir dans les
semaines et les mois qui viennent si Guy
Carcasson avait raison en tout cas je
vous remercie de nous avoir éclairé de
vos lumières merci à vous qui nous avez
écouté vous pouvez revoir cette émission
sur le site de publicsenat.fr
et nous nous retrouvons pour la
prochaine émission merci
bonsoir